well now this is what happens now so in
the show's over no we could have one
last thing we have a email asking a
question but hold on just a minute
how long could you go do this with me
like count well you guys could probably
go on for hours
both of you the longest you ever went
was probably an hour 20 minutes with who
maybe Jordan Peele
Jordan Wow what I mean
someone wants to break the record I'm
just saying here's why I do it that way
though and I know that people listening
right now go how come you always say are
we what time were because we want to
hear two hours I always believe less is
more like a therapy session
yes and I believe that what I do
anything I try to compact the thing with
as much entertainment within a small
amount of space
yeah but how do you know an hour and 20
with me isn't gonna be but you know you
don't seem exhausted in this episode
this your your energies match you have a
frenetic energy you're calm so it can go
on for a while you have to people with
Unitas phonetic to write I give what I
get oh so you're get you're good right
now because I'm giving good no I'm
saying that I am able to match my scene
partner like if I can just you know
decide what what Wow
person Wow so you're you're a high level
right no no I'm I'm right here in the
middle because right your show you ever
gonna do a podcast
no it's for us for people yeah yeah no
it's not that's not what he meant baby
no no but I'm that's what I meant yeah
that's what I meant yeah
no I wouldn't I wouldn't do it because
why I never did stand like stand up in
that I don't know that I have that the
energy and passion to be good at hosting
a weekly podcast and I don't want to
just start saying I'm gonna do a podcast
now because I'm on a show I respect
people later than that Eric well I swear
to [ __ ] god I know
that you could do what dude was a
podcast or stand-up because you have the
connect kind of point of view you know
how to add information people are always
surprised by how angry I am in real life
that's the one thing I'm constantly
competing against my character yeah cuz
my characters really fun and nice and
I'm I'm I'm nice but I have a more of an
angry point of view in life and it
really yeah your edge year I was telling
them a but he's a little edgy he can you
know but I don't think that I've been
very nice you can't go you're great
tonight I've been very nice you you did
this you know me and this is the dead of
it very nice I wanna see the ring have
you been in a fist fight before yeah
yeah yeah all right I want to see the
angry side you don't have to be a pretty
baby you don't want to want to unleash
it I love angry people they're my
favorite what do you want I don't want
anything no when you were telling that
story like I would have had a real
conflict in that moment because I'm
thinking two things where was everybody
else when Ari Shaffir was hitting you
because had I been with you that night I
would have gone [ __ ] red light like I
would have yeah yeah I mean he's my
question but here's so Natasha came to
the store four months after that very
morons with her still yeah yeah and Ari
took a [ __ ] glass of water with ice
in it and threw it at her threw it in
her face to the shards of [ __ ] ice
one on her face oh my god and then dove
Davidoff and bryan callen were there and
they got up and they [ __ ] put you
know mean start put it was like you know
because they weren't there what I got
beat out Steve Rannazzisi you know I
mean unplugging the phone I'm friends
with both she's like I don't know what
he was in the league okay yeah I'm glad
yeah I'm so glad you said that - well I
might if I saw him I don't need a
question what's the question
[Music]